well what i love about this time is it's
a time for reinvention
i mean this is one of the advantages of
disruption
which is customers tend to be a little
more patient i mean remember we got very
used to
our amazon packages showing up the next
day you know if it showed up in three
days we'd be like what's wrong
well now things were showing up in two
weeks and three weeks and everybody was
fine with it
and here we are doing off-sites with you
know
standing in our in our in our homes
talking to each other
and people are patient with us we
couldn't have gotten away with this
a year ago it would have to be beautiful
beautiful and lights and cameras and
studios
but people are patient they understand
and so this is an amazing time for
reinvention
it's an amazing time for experimentation
and that goes for companies as well
as well as it does for individuals which
is we can reinvent ourselves we can
reinvent our jobs
in fact some of us will be forced to
reinvent our jobs because if we're in
this startup mentality
something i used to do may not be
necessary anymore and now i get to
change what i could do or what i want to
do um
so it's an amazing time for reinvention
and for experimentation as far as
leadership goes and i talk about this
all the time
leadership has nothing to do with rank i
know many people who sit at high levels
of organizations who are not leaders we
do as they tell us
because they have authority over us but
we
would not follow them and yet i know
many people in much lower levels of an
organization who have no formal
authority no formal rank and yet they've
made the choice to look after the person
to the left of them
and they've looked made the choice to
look after the person to the right of
them and we would follow them anywhere
and so if we are not the leaders of the
organization
we can still be the leaders we wish we
had and
leadership is not about being in charge
it's about taking care of those in our
charge
it's a the awesome responsibility to see
those around us rise
and so we can be leaders we can check to
the people to the left we can check to
people to the right
it's what i said before about uh whether
you were an effective or ineffective
leader
uh before you picked up the phone and
called your people well that can happen
at any point
and by the way it can also go up the
chain of command you know someone
who's who's mid-ranking can pick up the
phone and call their boss and say
are you okay you seemed a little out of
it in the meeting today and i'm worried
about you are you okay that's called
leadership
and so we need leadership more now than
ever
because leadership is the is is that is
that responsibility to take care of
people and that's what we need to feel
so i encourage people to be the leader
they wish they had
you